[음악]
안녕하세요 빌사남 부동산 중개법인
전환성 중개사입니다 오늘은 강남구
청남동 위치한 통임대 건물을 소개해
드리려고 하는데요 해당 건물의 위치는
7호선 청담역에서 도보 약 10분
거리에 위치해 있고 올림픽대로 강백
블로와 인접한 도산대로 바로 이면에
위치해 있어서 교통 접근성 또한
우수한 위치에 자리잡고
있습니다 해당 건물의 인근으로는
명품거리와 연애 계획사 등 다양한
업종의 오피스 등 인접해
있습니다 해당 건물의 대지 면적은 약
101평 옆면적 약 46평 지하
3층부터 지상 5층까지 총 여덟 개
층의 신축 통사고
건물입니다 건물의 외관을 보시면
웅장하고 고급스러움을 느끼실 수
있는데요 건물의 상부층은 다크
그레이톤의 롱브릭 타일로 마감하였고
저층부는 깔끔한 라임스톤 벽제로
마감되었습니다 주차장 통로 부분은
LED 레일 조명으로 화려하고 세련된
느낌 더해져
있습니다 기계식 주차로 총 일곱
대까지 수용할 수 있고 주차 관리실도
따로 배치되어 있어 추후에는 발레
주차도 협의하실 수
있습니다 지상 3층부터 지상
5층까지는 야외 테라스 부분을 전면
통창으로 배치되어 내부 공간이 답답함
없는 개방감과 체강 또한 매우
좋습니다 지상 1층에는 20평대 넓은
야외 테라스 공간이 마련되어 있으며
휴계 공간으로 이용하실 수 있도록 잘
분리되어 있습니다
전층 내부 공간에는 중앙 기둥이 없다
보니 깔끔한 레이아웃을 적용하기에
좋아 보이며 기본적인 내부 마감까지
모두 완비된
상태입니다 모든 층에는 깔끔하고
고급스러운 남녀 분류 화장실이
배치되어 있고 천장형 시스템 에어컨이
층별로 두 대부터 세대까지 설치되어
있습니다
[음악]
us
h
[음악]